all right you guys know literally my
favorite thing about the internet is
watching old news bloopers and I believe
we have some of them right now at 11 pay
more at the grosser but getting less
will tell you how to get the
most what are you
doing I just love this one I just love
this one we need to acknowledge an
unfortunate mistake that I made and one
of the teases we bring to you before
this program why we live just after
10:00 I said a word that many people
find offensive I'm truly sorry it was a
mistake on my part and I sincerely
apologize I just love I love that one
because I'm from New York so it's Chuck
Scaro is the guy she's talking to and
that's Sue Simmons and they were this
legendary Duo she calls it a mistake and
a word is like what was he doing like
what was Chuck scarbo sorry one one more
time we won't double play most of them
but there's something about this one I
just love at 11 pay more at the grosser
but getting less will tell you how to
get the most the are you
doing like what is he doing was he
masturbating like what was he
doing all right and then the apology I
said a word and also it's because it's
so seamless you know what I mean like
there's no pause she just assumes that
they're going to commercial the second
they're supposed to go all right what do
we got uh what's uh what's the best kind
of firework to buy wouldn't you like to
know weather
boy where are your parents
kid sketchy back to
you get us in touch with that kid I want
to I want to send him something for
Christmas that's great that's weather
boy all right you have to be really
careful out there you do we've had sex
six rather consecutive days of R whoa
did I okay all right that was a Freudian
slip but we're going to pretend like we
didn't hear it oh he's good he's good
all right I like that guy like that's
what I'm talking about like the ones
that can just like Smooth L roll out
that's nice the ones that are so stiff
are the funny ones all right the dog in
Thailand is certainly giving new meaning
to the phrase doggy sty doggy paddle
excuse me he was found swimming 135
miles off the shore of Thailand oil rig
workers first spotted that I
don't I know there's no way around it so
workers first
spot doggy style doggy style that's
right Action 7 reporter Christine pay is
at the scene with what we know
apparently we don't have that story
right now astronomers at the University
investigation in Southwest
Al we'll do it
live I don't know how you could do like
the on camera thing for a living and not
love it to the degree that if something
really screwed up you'd still find it
funny or happy or joyous or something
all
right that's it that's all we got people
see look there was a little screw up
there at the end you
don't